we know more about other planets than
our own and today I want to show you a
new type of robot designed to help us
better understand our own planet it
belongs to a category known in the
oceanographic community as an unmanned
surface vehicle or USV and it uses no
fuel instead it relies on wind power for
propulsion and yet it can sail around
the globe for months at a time so I want
to share with you why we built it and
what it means for you a few years ago I
was on a sailboat making its way across
the Pacific from San Francisco to Hawaii
I just spent the past 10 years working
non-stop developing video games for
hundreds of millions of users and I
wanted to take a step back and look at
the big picture and get some much-needed
thinking time I was the navigator
onboard in one evening after a long
session analyzing weather data and
plotting our course I came up on deck
and saw this beautiful sunset and a
thought occurred to me how much do we
really know about our oceans the Pacific
was stretching all around me as far as
the eye could see and the ways were
rocking our boat forcefully a sort of
constant reminder of its untold power
how much do we really know about our
oceans I decided to find out what I
quickly learned is that we don't know
very much and the first reason is just
how vast oceans are covering 70% of the
planet and yet we know they drive
complex planetary systems like global
weather which affect all of us on a
daily basis sometimes dramatically and
yet those activities are mostly
invisible to us
ocean data is scarce by any standards
back on land I had grown used to
accessing lots of sensors billions of
them actually but let's see in situ data
is scarce and expensive why because it
relies on a small number of ships and
buoys how small a number was actually a
great surprise or National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration better known
as NOAA
only has 16 ships and they are less than
200 buoys offshore globally it is easy
to understand why the oceans are an
unforgiving place and to collect in-situ
data you need a big ship capable of
caring vast amount of fuel and large
crews costing hundreds of millions of
dollars each or big buoys tethered to
the ocean floor with a four mile long
cable and weighted down by a set of
train wheels which is both dangerous to
deploy and expensive to maintain
what about satellite you might ask well
satellites are fantastic and they have
taught us so much about the big picture
over the past few decades however the
problem with satellites is they can only
see through one micron of the surface of
the ocean they have relatively poor
spatial and temporal resolution and
their signal needs to be corrected for
cloud cover and land effects and other
factors so what is going on in the
oceans and what are we trying to measure
and how could a robot be of any use
let's zoom in in a small cube in the
oceans one of the key things we want to
understand is the surface because the
surface if you think about it is the
nexus of all air sea interaction it is
the interface through which all energy
and gases must flow all Sun radiates
energy which is absorbed by ocean as
heat and then partially released into
the atmosphere gases in our atmosphere
like co2 get dissolve into our oceans
actually about 30 percent of all global
co2 gets absorbed plankton and micro
release oxygen into the atmosphere so
much so that every other breath you take
comes from the ocean some of that heat
generates evaporation which creates
clouds and then eventually leads to
precipitation and pressure gradients
create surface wind which move the
moisture through the atmosphere some of
the heat radiates down into the deep
ocean and gets stored in different
layers the ocean acting as some kind of
planetary scale boiler to store all that
energy which later might be released in
short-term events like hurricanes or
long term phenomenon like any no these
layers can then can get mixed up by
vertical upwelling currents or
horizontal currents which are key in
transporting heat from the tropics to
the poles and of course there is marine
life occupying the largest ecosystem in
volume on the planet from microorganism
to fish to marine mammals like seals
dolphins and whales but all of these are
mostly invisible to us the challenge in
in studying those the ocean variables at
scale is one of energy the energy that
it takes to deploy sensors into the deep
ocean and of course many solutions have
been tried from wave actuated device to
surface drifters to Sun powered
electrical drives each with their own
compromises our team breakthrough came
from an unlikely source the pursuit of
the world speed record in a wind-powered
land yard it took ten years of research
and development to come up with a novel
wing concept that only uses three watts
of power to control and yet can propel
vehicle all around the globe with
seemingly unlimited autonomy by adapting
this wing concept into a marine vehicle
we had the genesis of an ocean drone now
these are larger than they appear
there are about 15 feet high 23 feet
long 7 feet deep think of them as
surface satellites the Ladin with an
array of science grade sensors that
measure all key variables
oceanography and Atmospheric and the
live satellite link transmits this
high-resolution data back to shore in
real time our team has been hard at work
over the past few years conducting
missions in some of the toughest and
ocean conditions on the planet from the
Arctic to the tropical Pacific we have
sailed all the way to the polar ice
shelf we have sailed into Atlantic
hurricanes we have rounded Cape Horn and
we have slalom between the old rigs of
the Gulf of Mexico this is one tough
robot let me share with you a recent
work that we did around the Pribilof
Islands this is a small group of islands
deep in the cold bering sea between the
u.s. and russia now the Bering Sea is
the home of the walleye pollock which is
a whitefish you might not recognize but
you might likely have tasted if you
enjoy fish sticks or surimi
yes siree me looks like crab meat but
it's actually pollock and the Pollock
fishery is the largest fishery in the
nation both in terms of value and volume
about 3.1 billion pounds of fish coat
every year so over the past few years a
fleet of ocean drones has been hard at
work in the Bering Sea with the goal to
help assess the size of the pollock fish
stock this helps improve the quota
system that's used to manage the fishery
and help prevent a collapse of the fish
stock and protects this fragile
ecosystem now the drones survey the
official the fishing ground using
acoustics ie a sonar this sound sends a
sound wave downwards and then the
reflection the echo from the Sun away
from the seabed or schools of fish gives
us an idea about what's happening below
the surface our ocean drones are
actually pretty good at this repetitive
task so they have been grading the
Bering Sea day-in day-out
now the Pribilof Islands are also the
home of a large colony of fur seals in
the 1950s they were there were about 2
million individuals in that colony sadly
these days the population has rapidly
decline and there's less than 50% of
that number left and
population continues to fall rapidly so
to understand why our science partner at
the National Marine Mammal Laboratory
has fitted a GPS tag on some of the
mother seals glued to their furs and
this tag measures location and depth and
also has a really cool little camera
that's triggered by sudden acceleration
here is a movie taken by an artistically
inclined seal giving us unprecedented
insight into an underwater hunt deep in
the Arctic and the shot of this Pollock
prey just seconds before it gets Devore
now doing work in the Arctic is very
tough even for robots they had to
survive a snowstorm in August and
interferences from bystanders that
little spotted seal enjoying a ride
now the ctags
have recorded over 200,000 dives over
the season and upon a closer look we get
to see the individual seal tracks and
the repetitive dives we are on our way
to decode what is really happening over
that foraging ground and it's quite
beautiful
once you superimpose the acoustic data
collected by the drones a picture starts
to emerge as the seal leave the islands
and swim from left to right they are
observed to dive at a relatively shallow
depth of about 20 meters which the drone
identifies is populated by small young
Pollock with low calorific content the
seals then swim much greater distance
and start to dive deeper to where a
place where the drone identified larger
more adult Pollock which are more
nutritious as fish and fortunately the
calories expanded by the mother seals to
swim this extra distance don't leave
them with enough energy to lactate their
pups back on the island leading to the
population decline further the drones
identify that the water temperature
around the island has significantly
warmed and might be one of the driving
force that's pushing the Pollock north
and to spread in search of colder
regions
so the data analysis is ongoing but
already we can see that some of the
pieces of the puzzle from the first
sealed mystery are coming into focus now
if we look back at the big picture we
are mammals - and actually the oceans
provide up to 20 kilos of fish per human
per year and as we deplete of fish dogs
what can we humans learn from the first
seal story and beyond fish the oceans
affect all of us daily as the drive
global weather systems which affect
things like global agricultural output
or can lead to devastating destructions
of lives and property through hurricanes
extreme heat and floods our oceans are
pretty much unexplored and undersampled
and today we still know more about other
planets than our own but if you divide
this vast ocean in six by six degrees
squares each about 400 miles long you'd
get about a thousand such squares so
little by little working with our
partners we are deploying one ocean
drone in each of those boxes the hope
being that achieving planetary coverage
will give us better insights into those
planetary systems that affect humanity
we've been using robots to study distant
world in a solar system for a while now
now it is time to quantify your own
planet
because we cannot fix what we cannot
measure and we cannot prepare for what
we don't know thank you
[Applause]
[Music]